Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and just checking in on you for the Thursday
afternoon,
Monday morning podcasts,
and I'm doing on Friday just to fuck with all your drug users out there.
It's paid a or it's the day after pay day.
You go out and blow it and get some whores,
a little bit of blow or whatever.
So you probably be breaking my balls saying why am I a day late and a dollar
short.
I am not a dollar short.
I'm sitting here in the all things comedy studio with the one and only star of
last man on earth.
Mr Will Forte.
Hello Bill.
How are you sir?
I'm doing great.
It's,
it's a beyond a thrill.
So I screwed up.
I screwed up the schedule and,
and uh,
this should have been Thursday.
No,
no,
not at this is all right.
I mean I want it done Thursday if you weren't on it,
but people understand that I'm going to wait.
Ah,
yeah.
For someone like,
yeah,
absolutely.
Now,
I'll tell you if it was like a reality show star,
I just be like,
it's not going to work out.
We're going to have to reschedule for another Thursday.
No,
no,
absolutely man.
I was psyched.
I finally ran into you.
Um,
I've been such a fan for so long.
I ran into at the night of too many stars.
Yes.
There was too many stars.
They're well and uh,
I got to watch you sing the song a wanted dead or alive with a bond,
Joe.
That was very exciting.
Then freshed it.
Oh my God.
I've just crushed,
screaming wanted though.
Crushed in the bad way.
I could have it,
but that was where we were supposed to do.
We're supposed to ruin his song.
Now wasn't,
the thing was they didn't want you to wear the hat because he didn't want like
Richie Sambora to see,
make it seem like you're a making fun of,
yeah.
Yeah.
There was some word on that.
There was,
there was a hat that we ended up not going with.
It just made me look even goofier do I got to tell you what they invest.
One of my favorite things about you is your,
your facial expressions.
I've never seen like the,
the desperation and like the characters you do,
the faces that you make like a,
like when Gruber or are on your new hit show there,
our last,
last man standing like the looks that you come up with.
Like it's called the last man on earth.
Not last man.
It's Stan.
Sorry.
Last Man on earth.
You know what I'm thinking?
Let down my mom doesn't.
My mom does that.
Did I say that twice every no,
no.
You said it,
you said it right once and last month.
Yeah.
I mean as long as you get last man.
Why I don't,
this is why I never have guessed what an asshole I'm going to write it down so
don't fuck it up.
Last man,
I just wrote to standing and I had to cross it last month.
Basically the last man standing.
Well for the first couple of episodes,
no spoilers.
Oh,
there's gonna be a bunch of spoilers cause I love the show and you know,
uh,
you know,
whatever,
shut it off.
I don't give a fuck.
It's a great show and I want to talk about it cause I'm a fan.
Um,
first of all,
how did you come here though?
The Look of desperation that you mentioned?
Is,
is something that I've,
I've basically workshop my whole life because I've basically been,
I kind of a desperate individual and it looks come very naturally to me.
How so?
Desperate,
I dunno.
Just desperate for,
I'm,
I'm a little OCD and a little,
a little,
uh,
everything kind of desperate for,
do you fix the for acceptance?
Definitely.
I would say that's probably,
you know,
I,
I used to have a real hard time like leaving a party unless I knew that I had
said goodbye to everybody.
It took me forever to,
you know,
it's like,
I dunno,
I didn't want people to be offended that I didn't say goodbye to them or
something like that.
And then you just learn,
oh,
that's right when somebody else leaves without saying bye to me and I'm friends
with them.
I don't think that our friendship is over.
Like it's all fine.
I Dunno.
So what'd you find yourself laying in bed at three in the morning?
Buzz going off.
Fuck,
I didn't say,
I didn't say hi to Mike.
Yeah.
And then it would make a special call the next day.
Hey,
sorry,
I didn't get to say,
but I'm not joking now.
Where did that,
what do you think that came from?
Uh,
I don't know.
Probably,
uh,
my mom who's a very,
very nice person and my sister.
Yeah.
And you seem really like down to earth.
How'd,
how'd you end up in this fucked up business?
You just seem like you're,
you're just like a meet.
I met you with like within two seconds I'm like,
this guy's a sweetheart.
Oh,
blushing.
Well,
I don't know.
You know,
I don't,
I,
you know,
it's,
it's weird because there are a couple ways into it and a lot of,
you know,
the,
the popular theory is that,
you know,
people,
uh,
um,
work out their aggression and their,
their horrible childhood childhoods up on stage and stuff.
And mine was a different,
different,
I mean,
we all got problems,
but,
but mine,
I had a supportive family.
I had a great upbringing.
Was Orville a tough name growing up that it was,
but I would,
I always went by will.
Oh,
you did?
Well that's not true.
I went by Billy for like five years and then,
uh,
I got teased because of Billie Jean King.
And so I said,
um,
I changed it.
I came home one day and just change it to will,
how,
why Billie Jean King?
We played,
uh,
no,
but just like,
you know,
she was very popular back then.
I'm 44,
so I was right.
It was probably 1975 and she was at the height of her tennis powers.
Wait,
you said he won in 1978 and by [inaudible] 75.
So you're five years old and the kids in your grade or like up on the woman's
movement?
It was a big tennis community.
This is northern California.
Oh,
all right.
It was a,
you know,
so did you make you made a conscious choice to switch from,
uh,
Billy to will?
Yes.
Because they were calling you a Billie Jean kink.
Yeah,
it hasn't nothing.
Uh,
yeah,
that was it.
If not,
you know,
I,
it's a fact.
It's not a great story.
It's just a fab shop.
Hey,
I was just,
I find it bizarre that kids at five years of age knew who the hell she was.
Did you hear,
did you hear that shit was rigged?
What was rigged?
I think living Bobby Riggs,
I was a Bobby Riggs Guy's last name was unintentional pun or was it a pun?
I Dunno what it wants and I'm cringing,
but like he wasn't like he could have kicked her ass end.
He didn't,
he'd like bed on her.
This is the seventh.
Are you serious?
Well,
I mean this could be like people who hate women so much.
We're actually creating this theory on the internet or it actually happen.
I hope it happened not out of some slam and women shit just out of some
degenerate gambler kind of thing.
Like if he was like in deep and they were going to break his legs or something
like that.
And I thought I'd tell you something right now.
You whatever the fuck his name is,
Bobby,
he got to lose.
You got to lose the Billy.
Well this is fucking,
you are going to want to kill you or something.
I Dunno.
I,
I think she might have beat him.
Fair and square.
She was pretty damn good.
I mean,
I was named after her for like five years,
so I've got to stick up for her action.
She should have destroyed them.
That they actually bugged me.
I hate all women thought that that was like a victory.
It's like you want your beat an old man.
You had the champion of your sex playing this old man.
I mean,
I mean at some point,
Bill,
I'm staying out of this one.
You and your God,
northern California.
You guys.
Yeah,
just,
you guys are,
I guess really nice people.
So anyway,
it isn't,
I will say it a lot of really nice people up there.
It's a,
it's a no math,
no heroin.
There's,
you know,
there's probably like,
it's creeping in everywhere.
What did,
I didn't see a lot of it.
I didn't see a lot of meth and heroin.
I is it me?
Am I crazy?
Was meth and heroin,
was that just kind of around when it was over and meth wasn't around when we
were kids.
Yeah.
I think I'm actually going to be doing a Gig and you Rica,
California and a way north.
And I was excited about that.
And then somebody,
you know,
I don't know if they just show,
you never know what the Internet,
like they just sit there and they just constantly just go the negative route on
everything.
But they were saying that it was a little shady.
I'm I kind of fuck,
how could that place be shady?
It's nestled up there in the redwood forest.
Like I would think people would just be a,
I don't know.
Yeah,
leaving pies on the window sill.
Like,
well,
I mean Albuquerque.
I bet that was where we made macgruber and,
and you know,
that's obviously we're a breaking bad was set.
And so there's presumably a huge,
a math situation up there and there are a lot of great things about Albuquerque.
So I think you're going to find some very,
very big positives in your recap.
It must be like a,
I assume a lot of history of the gold rush.
Please drive cross country with you and I'll just keep going negative and he'd
be like,
you know what I think about the home city that's kind of have some surprisingly
mom and pop kind of places.
I knew when I watched your show,
I was saying to my wife,
I go,
this looks like,
uh,
this,
this looks like where they shot breaking bad and I'm just going to know it's a
desert.
But for some reason it looked familiar a little bit,
some of the landscape and uh,
and she for some reason thought it was like an Arizona or something.
So that makes me feel good.
Wait,
no,
no.
Uh,
uh,
last man on earth is Arizona,
but we shoot it in Chatsworth but,
but macgruber was Albuquerque.
I'm a group of us.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All right.
Jesus.
How bad on my fucking this up or you are doing great.
And I do want to drive cross country with you.
It sounds really cool.
I have to ask you,
after years of being in this business and bringing off not even remotely as
crazy and ideas what you have with our last man on earth,
like how the hell did you not only get that on the air,
how did you get that a on like fox?
I mean I should preface this for people who haven't seen it,
it's basically the post apocalyptic and as far as you know,
your character is the last person on earth and doing all this crazy shit that
you would do when you were by yourself.
How did you uh,
Jeez,
I'll tell you,
come up with it.
It was uh,
Chris Miller and Phil Lord are a huge reason for it because they're,
they're the guys who did the Lego movie in 2122 jump street,
cloudy with a chance of meatballs and we've been buddies for years.
So they asked me if I wanted to write something with them.
And the got there.
I mean they are having such amazing success right now that,
that,
you know,
people are lining up to work with them.
So,
so I just got in at the right time and we all came up with this idea together.
How long did it take to you to get to that?
Cause he was just probably like,
all right,
where'd you grow up?
What was your childhood like?
And they try to mine that type of thing.
Like how do you go from the usual,
Whoa,
like,
cause this is like one of the most original ideas for a show I've seen in a long
time.
Oh God,
thank you.
Uh,
uh,
we'd sat around for about three days and uh,
you know,
just three full days.
We brought up the last man on earth kind of early in the process and just went
right by it.
Um,
I don't know.
We just didn't seem right to us.
And then we had settled on this other,
uh,
show idea.
It was actually,
it was about,
uh,
Val Kilmer used to,
he stayed with me for awhile because he,
we became buddies through macgruber.
And then he,
he all,
this is in real life.
This is in real life.
I don't,
he ended up staying with you.
He stayed with me,
uh,
because he,
he has a place in New Mexico,
but,
but he wanted,
uh,
he,
he likes to have a place in Malibu as well.
Well,
he was leaving this one place and wanted to look for another place.
So he just needed a place to stay for what I thought was a couple days and he
just couldn't find the right place.
So it ended up being several months.
So that was what we were going to write the show about it.
It's going to be kind of,
uh,
fictional.
I kind of partly fact,
did it get weird at some point where you're like,
well,
I gotta tell Val Kilmer to a,
hey man,
it's such a weird thing.
Like it's not,
he's a bump.
It's like,
dude,
can you hurry up and find a mansion?
No.
It was in the ocean to tell you it was the best couple months of my life.
It was so much fun.
Uh,
you know,
he's,
he's like a member of the family,
so it's,
it's a,
um,
he's hilarious to like,
remember he's top secret.
Remember that way back day.
Oh my God,
his doc holiday.
Oh,
Wyatt Earp.
Tombstone.
Excuse me.
Oh man,
he's still,
he's the best.
He's so far.
Have you met him?
No.
Ah,
I never met him,
but I have him on your show.
He is so wonderful.
So he stayed with you and so smart and yet he was there for three months.
So we are going to write something about that.
Um,
and,
and I don't know,
for some reason we just couldn't figure out what's the,
cause there were a bunch of really fun things that happen in,
uh,
in real life.
But then it was like,
what's that blend of of fact and fiction and you know,
how does it,
so we were a little mixed up with that and right as we were,
so they really figure it out what's happening.
So they will probably going to go with the comedy thing is rather than,
cause there's no,
you can't get five years into this guy crashes with me.
We had a great time.
It's his best time of my life.
They probably were going to try to go the route that,
that the guy was annoying you when they would,
well we were,
we were just kind of base it on our own characters cause it was kind of like an
odd couple in a way.
But,
but,
but in an odd couple in which both people are kind of the,
uh,
the,
Oscars,
uh,
kind of mixtures of Oscars and Felix's like he's the,
he's the best but,
but it's,
you know,
it just,
there's some that actually it's very funny because we,
we thought about,
well,
while he was staying with me,
uh,
I was watching the amazing race that was,
that was,
I was really into that show at the time.
I still like it,
but I just have,
don't watch it that much anymore.
But he thought I was an idiot for watching it.
And then I got him hooked on it or,
I don't know,
just the wrong word.
Fascinated.
You got stuck into it.
So we,
for a short period of time,
we're planning to try to get on the amazing race together.
Uh,
that would have been,
he come,
we both called their agents and they're like,
no way you're doing this.
There is no way you,
I still think it would have been.
Yeah,
I still hold out hope that,
uh,
that will do it someday.
I had an idea a long time ago,
a good friend of mine and one of the best comedians ever sell Patrice O'neil,
right?
Oh yeah.
So we were,
uh,
he was crashing with me during this pilot season and um,
we were flipping through the channels and judge Judy was on and she was just
sitting there screaming and yelling and berating people and everything was just
fucking annoying.
Like,
just her whole like,
uh,
I don't know,
it's almost like just grandstanding to get ratings.
And I was,
came up with this idea.
I was trying to convince him to do what I was say,
listen,
either you sue me or I sue you.
Okay.
And we'll pay each other.
And then when we,
you know,
when the dust settles,
I'll just give you the money back and you give me my money back in cash,
nobody knows.
Right.
And the whole thing was so we could get on that show and then all we would do
was go on there and try to see how mad we could make her.
And just when she told us to shut up,
you keep interrupting her going lady,
lady,
just anything just to get into her ego.
And I just felt,
cause like so much of it just seemed like a cartoon to me and she was yelling
just to yell and they'll,
so there was so many like mouth breathing morons that they had on the show that
she was always going see super intelligence.
So I felt if we went on then we played the dumb or we played it,
the more her show biz sense would kick in.
Like all this is comedy gold.
And then once we got a mad and then you sorta start insulting her in and just
seeing if we could just make her lose,
how would I a great word were were you guys at that time were w could nobody's
perfect.
Nobody knew who maybe a now I don't think so.
I was trying to think you couldn't do that anymore.
He did a uh,
yeah.
Cause cause now at the Internet they'd look up,
they find out who you are.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I think they'd find out after they aired it and then they'd never had heard
again.
I don't know man.
I wish I would've,
I would've,
I didn't watch the American race,
but if I saw the two of you on there,
I would definitely watch it.
They ought to have a celebrity one now.
Fuck.
That might just,
just on their one.
So you know that he was on there with his dad.
That was one of my favorite,
uh,
thing like seeing him with his dad.
It was that they had such a sweet relationship.
Oh,
they didn't fight or anything.
They didn't really,
they were very supportive of each other.
And,
and Mike was paid cause uh,
kinda remembered everything.
But I remember his,
his dad was not as,
uh,
as fast as him,
but Mike was incredibly patient and uh,
they were great.
It was just so much fun watching them and I thought,
God,
I want to go on the amazing race with my dad or val Kilmer.
Let me ask you this with you,
a nice laid back vibe.
How did you first react to New York when you went to New York during your,
uh,
did you go to New York first and then get on SNL or did you have like a other
gigs brought you there?
I W I,
I went there for SNL,
but it wasn't my first time I was there.
I wrote for Letterman for about God,
nine months in 97,
98.
It was my,
my first job ever was the Jenny Mccarthy sketch show on MTV.
And then I got a chance to write it Letterman right after that,
that job.
It was,
it was terrifying.
Like he was,
you know,
in Layman's my,
you know him.
Oh yeah,
that's Martin.
That guy still has like an SNL Gary vibe.
Those Peter Sellers,
those are my four,
uh,
you know,
God and money python,
but they're like,
Letterman is,
is one of my,
my,
uh,
the,
you know,
one of the things that really shaped,
uh,
my comedy,
you know,
and,
and so to work at that show is really crazy,
terrifying.
And I sucked at it.
That was not good.
We know what we do,
a monologue,
so you would write and sketch pieces.
I was doing sketch pieces and,
and,
uh,
you know,
writing top tens and stuff like that.
And it was,
it was such an honor to be there,
but like,
I wished that I had a little more experienced before I went there.
And it was so tough because then these guys,
I was probably 27 at the time.
And then the guys who came in right after me,
uh,
we're coming straight from college.
I think there were 22,
and they were doing amazingly well there.
And,
and it was super easy for them,
their first job at a school and there were the guys who went on to create,
uh,
how I met your mother,
Carter Basic Craig.
We'll just born with that gift to be have.
I,
I can't,
I suck at that.
I tried writing for the SBS a couple of years in a row and um,
I was just,
I,
I just never wrote like that.
Did you have to do the pattern stuff?
I think when they go up to the,
uh,
you know,
to announce awards.
No,
you got it.
Oh,
that's the worst.
Louie CK talked about that on,
on,
on Opie.
And Anthony was saying that like what the pattern that they come up with.
Believe it or not,
that's the best you can do.
You want to do something cute,
you do it,
you get in,
you get out.
And that's it.
I never had to do that.
I had to do like monologue jokes,
but like I just never had written from that.
Like,
like,
okay,
bill,
we need some volleyball jokes and you just sit in there going,
all right,
volleyball.
And he's just staring at that blank page.
I just felt like I was back in high school.
Again,
it's this,
I've just always written from like,
you know,
that bugs me,
I'm going to talk about that,
but now all of a sudden you're like writing for somebody else.
So like,
you know,
it's a good job,
but isn't that really in his style?
It's too mean spirited.
I got a lot of that and like it was still a great experience,
but just trying to,
um,
to do like I had already respected writers,
but to actually had have had a couple of those jobs,
it was a,
Oh,
I quickly realized it was like this,
this is not for me.
Yeah.
This is not something that when you get an idea,
do you write it down on like,
I used to have these notepads and wood.
Is that,
how do you remember your ideas?
That's how ideas,
that's how I used to do it.
I used to,
back in the day,
I was working in a dental office with my dad and these little Manila envelopes
said it.
You'd put the,
uh,
the x rays and after I take an x Ray,
pour up a model of some shit.
Right.
And,
uh,
I used to just write them down.
I used to write on,
but I would be writing up the whole idea.
Yeah.
You know,
and hoping that,
you know,
didn't want to lose any of it.
And then I try to transfer to notebook and then just became those little Manila
things.
Then it just keeps,
just became like one word.
And now it's just like a,
occasionally I'll type it into my phone.
Yeah.
Um,
but I,
I kinda just,
I dunno,
I just see something and go,
I'm talking about that.
And then if I remember,
I go on stage and I talk about it and if I forget,
I'm like,
uh,
I just,
I let it go.
I don't want to look at my,
I know,
I think I have like a little section in my phone.
Oh,
I got,
I got all kinds of shit in here.
Let me see what you got.
Okay.
No,
just write.
You just write one word.
No,
I wrote bad jokes.
These are,
I wonder,
remember bad jokes.
Uh Oh,
these are,
so
here,
I'll throw a couple of these out.
Um,
I have a series of me and my buddy have a these dumb,
uh,
who's on first type jokes,
but they involve,
um,
like for instance of Anagen.
If I see a van again,
I say,
oh my God,
look,
um,
I used to have a van again.
Wait,
is that,
did you ever quit?
I used to have a van again,
this is already off all this is why it's in the bad joke section.
I used to van again.
Oh,
that's crazy.
I don't remember you having a van a in the first place.
No,
I never had a band.
But you said you had a van again?
No,
I,
yes,
but you never had a van in the first place.
You never know.
It's,
it's really bad.
So then I wrote down different a Cardigan we could do with Greg Evigan Toboggan.
Okay.
That's horrible.
Then I have,
no matter what speed you're going,
you're always going this fast when you're going through an airport terminal
velocity,
that's not even a joke.
That's just,
yeah,
I said bird seed.
It's so overrated.
Know what I think about bird seed.
It's for the birds.
You know what's this is mining and I do stand up.
I could,
right?
Oh yeah.
I have down here it says,
be in the back laughing at this.
This is the worst.
It says ricotta.
Be Kidding me.
Like ricotta,
cottage cheese.
Uh,
yeah.
I like,
Oh,
here's this one's great.
here are two that are great.
I like Dublin,
but there's one place I like slightly more tripling.
Boom.
Bam.
Uh,
uh,
yeah.
I go to this great dive bar.
Greg Louganis is there all the time.
Okay.
I actually liked that one.
I asked.
Those are the kinds of jokes I send to my wife just doing Neuer.
I sent him one the other day.
I said,
what did the fashion needs to say to his son?
I'm proud of you like Prada shoes just to watch her fucking grown and send these
things back to a horrific,
but I just don't think any of these are good.
That's they're,
you know,
they're supposed to be bad,
but I don't have a thing in here that says good jokes.
These are just,
I only like remembering the bad ones.
I got in my phone right here.
I have,
I don't Kanye West.
And then it says dictator.
Even I as a white dude have unfulfilled dreams as a dictator.
I didn't know what that means.
And then the cruise ships,
cruise ships.
Now there's this thing that I'm doing that if I took over the world,
um,
my ethnic cleansing would be sinking cruise ships.
So it wouldn't be race or religious spoken.
It would be all be based on people killing.
They're killing people who are dumb enough to think going on a cruise is a good
idea.
But that's something that I'm working on.
There is like,
there's,
you know,
the Norwalk virus that kind of takes here at some of that.
It's going to happen.
I'm going to ask you,
doing the last man on earth with creating that thing where you guys,
any,
there's gotta be some,
somebody in there has got to be a little bit of a conspiracy theorist or
somebody's paying attention to the fearful talks about global warming.
Like you see the shit on the Internet saying California.
He's going to be out of the water in a year and you're just like,
why am I still paying my mortgage?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I get terrified by that stuff,
that the new one.
I've always been scared of earthquakes,
but the one that I keep hearing about is like super volcano stuff.
Um,
have you heard of that one?
What's that one?
Apparently there are a couple gigantic volcanoes that blow every couple hundred
years and there's one somewhere close to us that's the way overdue.
And so we're worried about these earthquakes,
but there's going to be a super volcano that's going to love.
I just can't wrap my head around that.
That could ever happen to me.
I just feel like you're going to be in France at the time.
I know you're going to be in France,
you're going to be safe.
Why?
Because I had just know you're going to survive this.
How do you know I'm gonna be in France because I just have this feeling you
don't have the shining,
you know?
I'll tell you how fucked up that is.
I was actually talking to my wife about an exit strategy out of this business
because nobody seems to ever work on it.
Yeah.
Like how you going to get out of it gracefully?
How are you going to walk away?
Like the way Seinfeld did law and I said he's out of the business,
but the way he had that great show fucking killed and guy,
what are you do now?
He did.
I said,
yeah,
I don't know,
maybe do some stand up.
And he just chilled until he came up with the next idea.
The uh,
the comedians in cars,
things like,
or like Johnny Carson or flip Wilson.
You get your money.
Like that's the hardcore one.
Uh,
Marvin Hagler.
Yeah.
You know,
really I didn't beat sugar ray Leonard.
Go fuck yourselves.
And he moved to Italy.
It starts making like macgruber type movies over there.
So I was thinking,
I'm 23 years and I'm 46 going to be 47 and another 23 years I'll be 69,
70.
I'm thinking that's a good possibly time to just walk and 70 and 70.
I either walk and I either,
it's either I'm going to buy a place in Paris,
sell all my shit live there,
and finally become bilingual.
Right before I Croak or Alabama.
I said,
I'm not joking either.
Why Alabama?
I like it there.
I just,
I like it.
I actually love the south.
I like why home?
All those fucking states.
Everybody Shits on.
I love him.
No.
Oh my God.
You know,
I've just never on spelled.
I never have all of those places.
That's not true.
I drove through uh,
Alabama,
but it was late at night.
Um,
I was driving from New Orleans to end to Texas and uh,
so I don't know Alabama too well,
but God,
I love Florida.
I love New Orleans.
No,
I was going from New Orleans.
Excuse me.
For Florida.
You to Orleans.
Yeah.
So I didn't,
I didn't want to be at,
yeah,
the road kind of know I made that.
I figured out that actually you would not go through Alabama.
Uh,
where,
where in Alabama do you think you would wind up?
Like Tuscaloosa?
Uh,
college?
Yeah,
I would definitely to Alabama is right.
Yeah.
That's okay.
I would make a decision if I was going to be an Auburn or Alabama fan.
And at this point,
just because I've been into Lsu,
like I just got into them,
you know,
watching their crazy coach there.
It's just so much fun rooting against Alabama.
Um,
and also like,
I mean,
people know I'm fucking around,
but like I,
I have like this,
this just based on nothing like sort of faulty hatred for Alabama.
I don't like the crimson tide.
So,
uh,
whenever they have a big game,
I always write Alabama.
The dream ends tonight cause like their dreams always won the championship.
It's just stupid.
And then I need really annoys people.
So,
yeah,
I think I would go,
uh,
maybe I'd be an Auburn Fan,
but I would have to live up in crimson tide country cause it'd be no fun to be
an Auburn fan around a bunch of Auburn fans.
This is the standup comic at me.
Like,
wait,
where's the fun in that?
Let's go annoy people.
And um,
you know,
when it's natural and it be,
I'm not trying to offend crimson tide fans either,
but like,
they are just such a powerhouse.
You always got to,
unless you are born into that,
you have to,
it's kind of like rooting against the Yankees or the Patriots.
Yes.
You know,
I'm a,
I'm an A's fan,
so the,
you know,
the Yankees are a natural enemy and I'm a,
I'm a Bruins fan.
I went to Ucla and,
and so I get,
you know,
I gotta be against,
uh,
Alabama.
They're just,
you know,
they're,
they're so good.
They're too good.
Yeah.
No,
that's,
I mean that,
it's actually,
I guess you shouldn't get mad.
It's,
it's a,
it's my brilliance are coming.
They're coming.
Oh yeah.
In Wa football.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
How'd you guys do last year?
I was on the road for the Aha.
See?
Uh,
we did all right.
We did pretty well.
We were like 10 and three.
I think that's great.
Yeah.
Right.
You guys won't like a flatline in that for a good 10 years.
I mean,
we have,
we had,
uh,
a couple,
we had some tight games than the beginning and then we really started getting it
together.
And then we had a couple,
a tricky ones against the,
you know,
Oregon so good.
And that was,
that was a tough one.
Those guys with that stupid uniforms,
they're ruined in football.
I got not,
not,
not cause the uniforms are bad.
It's because everybody's now trying to come up with a cool uniform and that just
not able to pull it off.
It's like they have Fonzie.
Everybody else needs to just fucking be plot seed.
How do you feel about,
is it eastern Washington that has,
or like Boise state,
the color,
the blue turf created.
They have the blue and uh,
eastern Washington has that crazy red,
uh,
I think it's desperate moves by schools that want to get noticed,
but at work,
cause now Boise is actually becoming somewhat of a,
a powerhouse.
I mean,
I don't know,
they kind of have the up and down,
but I also think that once they limited the amount of scholarships,
all of a sudden,
you know,
Appalachian State Beats Michigan,
that would never happen back in the day.
So,
um,
I dunno,
but I,
I,
you know what I realized with my add,
I never got around to it.
So,
uh,
coming up with the,
the,
the last man on earth.
Uh,
so,
so yeah,
so we were a,
with the val Kilmer.
Thanks.
Sorry.
No,
my God.
that's,
that's a,
that's a good memory right there.
Um,
no,
I,
you know what it is?
It's,
it's,
I read all the tweets when people shit on me,
so I have their criticisms.
Like in my head,
they're not necessarily bad.
They're like,
dude,
he was fucking about ready to say the thing and then you're interrupted.
So,
no,
this is the most boring part of it.
We did.
So we were,
we just had it all these lingering questions and we were about to go and,
and then I would be left to kind of figure out a route to this,
um,
val and we'll show.
And then we just on the way out,
Chris Miller's getting his jacket on and then I just said,
let's look at this last man on earth thing one more time.
And we just,
something a tiny adjustment was made and it just all started pouring out.
So it was,
uh,
you know,
we,
we got really excited about it.
We never thought that it would be a show for Fox.
It,
it definitely is weird.
As we were thinking it up,
it seemed like it was way more of a,
a cable type tone,
AMC,
FX,
FX or whatever they got now.
So we pitched it to,
uh,
you know,
a bunch of,
a bunch of people,
uh,
half of them cable,
half of them network.
And we were really,
we're just doing,
uh,
what was the name on pitches as a,
as a courtesy because we thought never would any of them,
uh,
be interested.
Uh,
the response was very good.
It was,
uh,
you know,
we had a lot of opportunities and,
but you know,
you go in there and you're partnered up with,
uh,
the studio,
which was a 20th,
and,
and they kind of help you decide where to do it.
And they,
they,
uh,
Fox was,
was very interested in and you know,
they,
uh,
they have a lot of history 20th and,
and Fox obviously.
So,
uh,
so,
you know,
it was decided that that was where we tried to do it.
And I gotta be honest,
I was a little nervous at first because I like to swear and had like,
well,
dirty situations that's going to say it.
Like when you guys were pitching that,
did you guys pitch the Margarita Pool and the toilet pool and didn't we,
uh,
did you come up with that afterwards?
That was part of writing the pilot.
That was part of writing the pilot,
uh,
that it was basically just the storyline of this guy's all alone,
doesn't know what to do.
And eventually all he's hoping for is,
is,
uh,
you know,
to see any other human.
And then finally another human comes into the picture and they just don't,
don't get along at all.
And you finally meet a woman you'd think and then it just becomes this,
you know,
played by the Great Kristen Schaal.
She's still unbelievable on that.
And I'm psyched to meeting to see another comic,
you know,
not only get,
she's killing it on the act of thing because there is sort of a stereotype,
you know,
sometimes about comedians act or whatever.
So she's doing us all a huge favor.
She's great.
And she in the ones that,
that haven't been aired yet,
she's even,
she likes,
she's asked to do a lot of,
cause she,
you know,
she played,
she's so funny and,
and,
and you know,
has always very easily access that.
But,
but this is like,
she is asked to do some very tough things where she's like still supposed to be
this fun,
crazy character we've created but also do like some kind of emotional things and
yeah,
just perfect at it.
She thought she's a great actress so I time for people to see that your,
your relationship,
your guys' relationship is driving me nuts on the show and I'm like yelling at
the TV going,
just dumper,
just do,
you can't let her move in and I'm just watching you getting sucked into this
relationship and like I would just feel like it's been enough to be alone.
This got to be somebody else out there and like fuck gives a shit.
If she moves in with you,
just go steal another house down the street,
just grab me shit and go down there and um,
I do,
I can't tell you enough about that,
that I just love like all this shit you would do when you're by yourself,
like driving your truck into stuff and bowling balls into fish tanks.
It's just like,
I mean,
I would do that,
but I also like,
yeah,
that's the,
I would do that too.
That's what the,
you know,
we,
we would just think up things that we would actually do ourselves.
Yeah.
Find a firework store and just,
just come up with you.
You turn it to like an eight year old.
Yeah.
But when I,
I liked,
oh,
with,
what's her cat?
The Carol character,
Kristen shells character.
How she is,
she still had morals,
so it was annoying and nagging is she is like this something that you still have
at the core?
Her,
she's like a really good person.
Oh yeah.
She's great.
She's,
she's,
you know,
that's the thing is that because I'm the last man on earth and we have to start
on me,
we have to kind of create this,
this sympathetic character.
But as the show goes on,
you realize like she's the,
she's the real good person here and,
and like,
and so your,
your,
your allegiances are constantly shifting.
Um,
so we're trying to,
you know,
we're trying to walk that tight rope and I dunno if I've gotten too far away
from it cause,
cause we don't want people to hate me forever.
But,
but I now do it.
Know your characters hilarity.
You can know,
you know,
you saw,
you had your morals is going,
you didn't leave Todd in the desert,
which was my life,
the way you guys shot that where you were like,
you know,
I'm not going to try to get away,
do whatever.
You know,
we've already shown you.
If people haven't seen it,
they they've uh,
shame on you.
You should have seen it.
You got to stay up to date or you're going to get spoilers released.
Exactly.
But how you just drop them off and I just loved the look on his face for he,
he,
he's such a good guy.
It doesn't register that you would leave him out there and he's in his size,
his white and middle of nowhere,
like three hour drive.
He's going to die and you're just driving away and then you have to scream and
like,
I can't do this.
This is morally wrong.
You keep backing up and then go,
no,
fuck it.
[inaudible] I'm totally butchering this.
The way you guys shot that thing.
Oh my God.
That was a Peter Atencio,
the guy who,
who directs all the key and Peele stuff.
He did that after a while.
I know him.
Um,
you would like him.
You would like,
I don't know if I haven't met him.
I'm the worst dude.
Like I,
I,
I act when they let me,
so I let a couple of times a year they'll get a gig and I'm meeting all these
cool people and then I'm just back out on the road doing my,
uh,
doing my,
my,
my stupid little at how,
how many days would you say you're on the road?
Uh,
not enough.
No.
I love it.
I absolutely fucking love it.
I love being a comic.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
At least at least half the year.
Maybe not.
Maybe not as not,
but it's not bad.
I mean every other week I work.
I mean that's a joke compared to back in the day when I had a job and had to be
there every fucking Monday through Friday.
Yeah.
And it's just like,
um,
I mean,
no wonder people like,
like there's no reason.
The only reason we,
for me to become an alcoholic,
it's just the downtime just out of boredom,
which is a pathetic reasons.
They keep you busy.
That's a pathetic reason to be an alcoholic.
But like anybody who's in the working world,
I totally get it.
Yeah.
It's just like,
it's just the buildup,
the bullshit Monday and that was,
it was the same deal.
It was like,
it would either be when I'm really,
really stressed out smoke or when I'm just really bored,
so I just had to be kind of busy.
But unstressed to not smoke.
No,
I just remember it by like Tuesday.
I always said Tuesday dragged worse than Monday.
Monday it was just,
he was so bleary eyed from the weekend before you knew what the Roach coach
showed up or was lunchtime.
But like Tuesday was just like,
that's when reality set in.
You didn't drink the night before you fucking sober and you just sit in there
going,
oh this is,
this is,
this is where I'm working.
Retired from Monday,
but you still have enough of the rest of the week that it sucks.
You're not like,
once you get to Wednesday,
it's like,
okay,
only two more days it's closing and we just stay with the worst for me.
And then Thursday you got your check and you got hope.
Who was the first time you had hope?
And then Friday felt like the last day of school and um,
yeah.
Then I just remember like literally running out of,
I worked in this warehouse,
which was a great job unloading trucks and ship and I just remember running out
of there and,
and just,
I don't know,
the weekend would go by in two seconds.
By Monday I was fucking broke.
I'd like no overnight,
no overhead or anything and I would come in,
I would just be absolutely broke.
And so Monday though,
I would make the people laugh,
telling my stories from the weekend.
That's how I'd get to lunch and then I just limped through,
but then,
but then Tuesday,
Wednesday,
which would just fucking kill me.
So whatever.
I'm getting,
getting back to the point,
if you have a drinking problem and you actually have a job,
I completely understand it.
Advocating alcoholism.
So I don't have a drinking problem.
I drink,
I fall down a don't know.
I get drunk.
I fall down.
Uh,
not a problem.
No problem.
There you go.
I ain't got to write that in my,
uh,
phone.
They could just put that on a tee shirt.
Hey.
Uh,
if you are into Boosie,
you know,
there's a really good whiskey.
Somebody turned me on to a cold alibi.
If you try it.
I've never tried it.
Oh my God.
I love,
I'm a whiskey whiskey and bourbon,
but not scotch.
It's not scotch whiskey.
Right.
I don't even know.
All I know is a couple ice cubes.
It's sounds like,
it sounds like it wouldn't be Scotch Alibi.
Sounds like it.
Yeah,
it's a whiskey and stuff.
I like.
It's the perfect.
Yeah.
If you just want to have a couple before you go to bed,
it's like 30 bucks for a bottle.
Just tear through the thing you're not worried about.
You know,
like when you buy actually buy something Nice,
you got to have like the whole,
the,
it's gotta be,
is this the right moment to open that bottle and you know,
don't put any,
don't put any fucking ice cubes in there.
This is just,
I dunno,
everybody's drinking makers,
everyone drinks jack or whatever.
It was just something different.
Somebody got me and uh,
I got a tour coming up,
going through the south with some buddies of mine and we're going to be on a bus
and I'm going to think of a stocking up and,
oh,
here we go.
I'm a whore myself out.
If the makers of alibi would like to send us some whiskey,
we'll talk about it on all our podcasts.
There we go.
That's,
that'll be like the end of me.
So I'm all right,
I'm jumping all over the place.
I got to go macgruber here.
Okay.
One of the funniest fucking movies of the last four or five years.
Absolutely loved it.
Paul Versey,
the buddy of mine who a headliner,
but every once in a while come around and open for me.
He,
uh,
he's the one who told me,
he said,
dude,
he goes,
you got to see this movie.
You went to go see what these two brothers.
And he said he was like punching one of them.
Fucking gravity.
The other one just watching it.
And um,
that's so cool.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Uh,
I was watching clips of it this morning.
I finally,
uh,
you know,
I was so busy I had to watch and refresh my memory and all that stuff.
Cause I forget movies a second.
I saw him,
I just like,
oh,
I'm going to ruin this movie too.
But just how you put together the whole t 40 is,
I grew up on those movies and they weren't trying to be funny.
No,
we was serious.
Roughly the same age.
And I,
the movies that we were were like,
this was our love letter to those movies that are the same movies that I
watched.
Uncommon Valor.
Right.
Uh,
you know,
diehard obviously and,
lead the weapon.
All those,
the 80s was just the golden age of those and they just kept coming out with a
guy.
There was,
there was the loan and then Schwartzenegger and then I won.
Then I,
and what's his face was in there?
Uh,
oh,
Mel Gibson.
L now Mel Gibson was in there.
What's this gay,
uh,
the guy with the red deer.
Chuck Norris.
Oh,
The guy with the red beard kicked me across the room.
Uh,
Delta force,
right.
Delta force.
Yeah.
Missing.
They missing in action trilogy with Tex Cobb.
I watched all of those.
Then there was a Sean Claude van Damme and before him,
was he before a Steven Seagal,
Steven Seagal.
I,
Dave,
I always have the two of those guys lumped together.
Ah,
no.
Do you know Judah Friedlander?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Judah will break down all of those movies and he'll,
he'll have you wanting to go.
I remember one time I was going,
what was that one way?
He was a,
they can't breaking everybody's arms and stuff like,
and he goes,
he's just like marked for death.
He's a great movie.
I go,
what was that one about?
He goes,
that was basically Steven Seagal beats up Jamaica.
And he introduced it and he gives him credit.
He goes,
he introduced the breaking of bones into martial arts movies.
Well before it was like people got knocked out,
they get kicked,
they get thrown across the fucking room.
They went through well,
but he actually like,
I swear to God that movie has like so many like Joe Theismann like bone breaking
them.
You gotta like look away.
But um,
so I got to ask you,
being a fan roadhouse also,
it was a big one for us.
It's just going to ask you,
Oh,
if that beginning scene has to be in Omaj to use that.
When you're in your Miata and you put your stereo in and they show you putting
your,
your glasses on,
it was that world house has that classic scene.
We're Swayze gets in the car and the show in the crotch gowns,
I Dah Dah.
And then a niche shown his car and at one point like they're shown all this cool
shit about him.
At one point he takes out a key,
see sliding cassette tape into is,
oh my God,
I don't,
you know what,
I,
I have probably only seen roadhouse once,
maybe twice.
And it was,
none of it was research for the show.
Oh,
okay.
So these were all just,
you know,
so if,
if it was an unconscious,
uh,
Omar,
if it was any kind of homage,
I mean,
definitely,
you know,
the,
those are the movies we loved,
but the,
but as with everything,
I usually,
my research consists of my tattered memories to remember
the whole philosophy behind roadhouse,
where it was just like,
this guy had this bar and he just couldn't keep it under control.
And like swayzees like this,
like almost like a national headline and comic.
But like,
he's a bouncer.
Like,
we gotta get this guy in here to start beating the shit out of the worst oil.
It's like,
why didn't you just call it cops?
Yeah.
You don't get a metal detector.
Maybe.
Maybe not over serve people.
Like why don't we start with the basics before you have to bring in like,
like this ringer to comment.
But I'm alone and watch roadhouse again now.
Now I'm excited to see it again.
Oh Dude.
It's,
it's one of the,
it's just,
that's where I think the throat rip,
uh,
didn't,
didn't they rip somebody,
throw it out in roadhouse?
Did they submit me?
Sure.
That I haven't seen in a while.
I just remember sways and leaning against the wall and the music was on and run
other than nodding his head down on the beat and he was doing this thing where
he was nodding it up,
which made it,
you made it look even more.
It's almost like he was saying hello to somebody across the bar and it was just,
hell is this?
So I don't know.
The guy's dead.
I shouldn't be shitting on his movies.
But I mean,
it's just,
it's,
I feel like you're glorifying them.
I don't,
I mean it's,
it's,
I love that movie.
We went too far in the other direction though.
Cause now I feel like every guy in so many of those movies,
a,
you know,
he doesn't have any expense himself.
He's awkward.
He's got his hoodie up and I just,
you know,
the whole,
uh,
my wife calls it the man boy,
you know,
the guy who was 35 but acts like he's on like a first date and like that whole
thing.
Yeah.
I just feel like that is,
uh,
was sort of the over that,
like that's the price we're paying for all of those,
you know,
uh,
missing in action movies.
Like now it's going to go completely the other direction.
So I'm trying to think how the hell they're going to mock those,
like the next generation of people mock and like those,
those types of movies that everybody grew up on.
But,
uh,
but I,
I asked people on Twitter to send me some questions for you and one of the
overwhelming ones was,
is there,
you know,
is there to be the macgruber part too?
Well,
we,
that's,
that's the plan.
We,
we've written about two thirds of an outline.
Um,
we,
uh,
very in depth outline and we really liked the stuff that's in there.
Um,
we have to figure out,
you know,
it's more just scheduling stuff.
Like we've been working on the last man on earth,
me and John Solomon,
r two,
two of the trio and then Norma Tacony.
He's working on a movie right now,
so,
so it'll be a while.
We're going to try to start writing.
How long does it take you?
A week or something.
How long does it take to shoot?
Macgruber was like 27 days.
27 work days.
So it was,
you know,
[inaudible] weeks or something.
I just love when you blow up your whole crew.
Like what's funny about you is you go with the real reaction like you do,
but for a different thing.
Like when like if you blew up your friends,
you just dropped he needs,
but you go like,
oh no,
no,
no.
It was like a cat was peeing on something in your house that you're going to
have lighter aware that night that's fucking killed me.
All of that,
like are like your facial expressions and all that type of shit.
Uh,
well by the way,
I don't even know if we,
we have some information that there are a couple of different people who might
be willing to,
to let us make the movie.
So,
so,
but you know,
we won't know until we actually like sending a script.
How did you come up with the salary bit in Macabre?
I needed a distraction.
Like were like,
all right,
I'm going to get punished ass naked and stick a piece of salary between my ass.
I think we were just watching,
uh,
but uh,
I know that Yurman John watched a bunch of MacGyver's and at while we were
writing and you know,
something,
one of us would be writing and they'd be watching stuff and writing also,
and they saw something in there where he,
uh,
he had had this table of things laid out and made it seem like he was about to
use every element of that,
uh,
to,
to cook up some kind of a contraption.
Yeah.
One of the things on there was a carrot and he said,
all right,
let's see what we got here.
And then you cut to him eating the carrot and he's just like,
he was hungry.
And so for some reason it did came from that.
Um,
and originally it was going to be a carrot and then we thought like,
oh well that,
that'll seem,
it already wasn't,
you know,
it was our own disgusting take on on that and it didn't really have anything
that,
you know,
obviously macgyver never serious.
He just stripped down and nothing behind something.
You grab your junk and you stick salary and you just walk out in front of a
camera crew.
That's why people go like,
Oh yeah,
you know,
like doing stand up.
All my God,
they like take so much courage.
It's like I told I walk out closed and if it goes wrong,
I blamed the crowd.
I mean,
it's easy.
Like you got a worse thing is my mom was there that day and not,
that wasn't even the worst thing.
My mom was there.
So we're at this warehouse and I looked,
you know,
I had done a couple of takes and I look over and there's my mom and she had two
friends with her.
Um,
so there the friends where,
you know,
my mom has kind of a pasted on smile.
Like that's my son,
that's,
he's doing this,
he's getting paid for this.
It's comedy.
It's kind of $12,000.
I made $12,000 from Gerber.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
And then her friends were just aghast.
They,
they,
these all northern California.
Nice.
Yeah.
Nice people,
wonderful people.
And I think they're,
they're,
you know,
at least they weren't there on the days when you were down on your knees going,
I will suck you with that.
I will let,
would've been,
I will let you fuck me.
My mom lost friends from,
cause my mom is the most supportive person in the world and cheese.
She brought several friends.
She would just,
my mom probably sound macgruber 20 times in the theater just so she could bring
different friends and some of them are no longer her friends because of that
movie.
Really.
Who Crystal wake,
who's one of the funniest people ever play in your ideal love interests.
And I loved it,
the keyboards.
So my favorite thing was when she whispered,
I love you at the end of the song,
but like your sex scenes,
w I mean,
thank God your mom didn't show up that day when you,
and then,
oh my God,
she's it.
Kristin was such a trooper because I believe guys,
like I was thinking you could probably get like 0.8 seconds before he'd start
laughing.
Like how long did it take you to shoot that it,
uh,
thank you for using the term shoot.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it was like probably two hours in this,
upstairs bedrooms.
So it's,
we're in Albuquerque in the middle of the summer.
It's already super hot everywhere.
You have these,
these lights,
uh,
burn and you,
you know,
and,
and so this room is just an oven and I am,
I,
I am a sweater.
If I get to a certain point,
I'm just,
I start sweating and it doesn't point out fucking yes.
Oh my God.
Like about four threats then.
And I just started helping her with,
with like huge drops of sweat and there was hair all over.
It was her birthday too.
So she was,
it was just the worst birthday of all time.
Oh my God.
But then they gave her a very special treat.
They,
cause we were in Albuquerque so they,
they like hooked her up with this special room in Santa fe where she could go
and shower off and get massages and get the experience out of her head.
Did you,
uh,
did you like what sort of mindset cause that cause you know,
I tried to get these acting gigs what every once in a while and like my big
thing is like having to,
you know,
the big thing that turning point for me when I finally actually started getting
jobs,
just to not be self conscious.
Like someone like you,
you seem the quiet,
reserved kind of person,
but like the,
the characters you play and how hard you commit to them.
Like,
wait,
where do you like man,
I'm just asking you like,
uh,
as a,
you know,
potential act or to,
to a great actor.
Like,
where do you go?
Like mentally before you just walk in like,
all right,
fuck this.
I gotta just,
I gotta do you have to psych yourself up to go 100%.
He one of those people like,
all right,
I'm just,
I'm this guy now,
so all my hangups disappear.
You know what it's,
I think it really is.
If you,
if you believe in the thing,
if you'd like what you're doing,
it's really easy to fully commit.
It's,
it's really hard when you,
when you think something is,
is not good to do that.
Do you have any examples early on without outing anybody that wrote something
and I know you,
you seem like you didn't want to shit on anybody.
So just different sketches that SNL,
uh,
you know,
when sometimes you would be asked to do somebody else's sketch and you were,
you have no say in it and uh,
or sometimes you would write your own little turd and,
and like he'd get out there and he'd go,
oh,
this is,
this is not good.
Oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
It makes it through the gauntlet of all those people trying to get a sketch on.
Yeah,
it makes it past Lauren.
It makes it passively,
they do like a little run through,
right?
Everybody's thinking.
It's funny now when it goes out there is,
and it just dies isn't,
well,
I mean it's,
the funny thing is like you,
you,
uh,
like at the Groundlings,
we,
we do shows that are,
are,
uh,
I'm,
I'm not there anymore,
but,
but when,
when we,
when you sign up to do a show,
you're doing the same show for about three months.
You know,
you,
you have this process where you're getting the show together and once you lock
in the show,
it's the same show,
you know,
for four nights.
You know,
when one show on Friday,
two shows Saturday night,
that same show for three months.
And there are nights when everything kills and there are nights that stuff just
totally falls flat.
So you just realize,
oh Geez,
it's,
it's the audience.
It can be anything.
So at SNL you're just,
you know,
some nights,
some nights it's definitely the materials.
Some nights you just have an audience that might be slightly older,
slightly younger,
you know,
you just,
you never know.
So sometimes you get really lucky and sometimes you get really unlucky.
Most of the time,
you know,
this stuff,
we'll get the shake that it deserves,
but,
but uh,
not always.
And what was your game plan if you're doing it?
Okay.
If you're,
you're on live television and you're doing a sketch and it bombs,
it's starting to bomb it signed the bottom,
you fill it bombing and then do you have like a thing where you're like,
you know,
whenever plow through this thing or I'm going to commit even harder or I'm not
trying to make the other person in the scene laugh or just some,
some way to try to pull some sort of victory out of it?
Or do you just try to get through it and pretend it never happened?
I'm pretty good about maintaining the level of commitment.
I'll never try to laugh.
That's,
that's uh,
a little bit of a cheat.
Um,
yeah.
And have was something that you break character?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I kind of go into hyperfocus.
It's not even that I don't like sometimes I think stuff's really funny and I
just,
I just am concentrating on not screwing up.
Um,
but like we did bill,
Bill Hader and I did this sketch with Josh Brolin called Fart face and he just
talked about it on Letterman.
I see.
I'm already handling this.
I wish you were in the audience that night because people hated it.
I mean,
it was,
it was how can you make fudge face?
I know,
right?
If,
and,
and it wasn't just that,
it's not like it wasn't gratuitous use of the aid was semi gratuitous use of the
term fart face,
but it was a business setting.
And these two very committed,
uh,
this emotional scene between two guys.
One of them is calling the other person that fart face and it's hard to
describe,
but we did it at the dress rehearsal show to complete silence.
It was almost,
it was almost so silent that it was a vacuum.
We almost opened up,
uh,
you know,
some kind of port horse.
So
we thought,
oh,
that's crazy.
I have,
I liked it.
I don't know.
I don't know why that audience didn't like it,
but you know what else?
We gave it our best,
uh,
who gave it our best try anyway,
we go up,
you know it,
what happens is you finish the dresser or a solo show,
you wait about a half hour,
then you go in to find out the pieces that are selected.
Now this was the night,
it was during that 2008 election cycle.
And uh,
Sarah Pailin was actually there that night.
She is,
Tina had already been doing her.
Sarah,
Sarah Palin,
this was,
I believe the night that Sarah Pailin herself actually came on to.
So this was a big deal of a show for SNL.
I think it ended up being the most watched SNL in years,
you know,
years and years.
Anyway,
we go in there and we see that fart face is somehow in the show.
It made it into the show.
I mean,
there were no laughs at all.
So it was,
I still,
you know,
it's a real testament to Lauren cause it was,
he thought he thought it was funny,
I guess.
Oh the one knows.
What did you guys say?
Lauren goes through and he does different notes during the,
during the,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
just too,
you know,
there was a,
there was this,
uh,
maybe a tread to speed up this,
during this and it goes to reach sketch.
And I just remember him coming to,
to ours and he says,
here's the boom shadow on fort face.
And that was it.
He goes on to the next thing.
So,
uh,
we go out there and it was just like,
we remembered the experience of no,
uh,
no laughter at all,
so we don't want to out there and wait,
what was the bill built?
I didn't remember this,
but bill told this on,
on Letterman.
I think he said that Josh Brolin came out and we were all sitting there.
It was like we were going into battle and Josh Brolin and says,
all right,
let's go shit these mother fuckers up or something like that.
I forget something like that.
Uh,
and,
and it was,
and we did,
we did,
we went out there if we,
but we gave it our all,
you know,
all three of us.
But it was,
I watched it,
um,
because when I heard bill talk about it,
I thought I got,
I want to watch this again.
We watched it
and I still stand by that sketch.
It's funny,
I don't know what the,
I don't know.
We really committed to it.
It's stupid for sure.
Um,
but I,
you know,
I,
I dunno,
you know,
some things you'd just,
that's,
there's no way if I went out there,
if I was with two other people and I'm doing something like fart face and it's
bombing,
I think I would start laughing.
I would like not laughing.
Like it would just make me want to commit harder to it and maybe stress Fart
face or make a weird face at somebody.
Just something that,
um,
I got this weird thing where I kind of enjoy like bombing a little bit.
Yeah.
Not Enough.
Not if I'm really,
like,
if I really believe in something,
if I really think of jokes,
good and the nightlife and then that gets frustrating.
But like,
um,
if I still know I'm being funny but it's bombing,
that's one of my favorite things.
I did a run through one time for this,
you know,
yet another failed pilot.
And um,
they said they wanted something edgy.
So we went super edgy and I guess it was way beyond what the fuck they thought
it was going to be.
And so we started doing the runs from in front of the network guys,
you know,
they come in,
it feels like the ACA has been fucking turned down even lower and they come in
and just the first thing dies at,
the second thing dies and,
and all of a sudden these actors I'm working with got this looks on their faces.
And then that became my motivation because that became my entertainment was
doing the scene and then passing other actors and they were shooting me looks
like going,
oh my God,
this is bombing.
And it just became my entertainment.
It was one of my favorite run throughs I ever did do.
When I tell you from the beginning to the end,
it was 22 minutes of silence.
Like we,
the thing started off,
been there.
Yeah,
it started off with that.
Why am I telling you that?
You don't know what it just like they literally started off with the guy playing
my friend,
a homeless guy comes up to us who they later said was way too homeless looking
way too dirty,
way to filthy.
He asked for money and I'm the liberals so I go to digging in my pocket to do
it,
to give them the money and my brother who's in a wheelchair grabs like some a
scoop of ice cream,
calls him a scumbag and flips it in his face and it totally like cut his beard
and like ended up in his hair and I remember hearing like an audible gasp from
the net with,
they're like,
oh,
like it was horrible and it just immediately VK.
I was like,
oh here we go.
We got one more scene if we don't get them in the next thing.
This thing has,
this is a runaway train.
It dude,
like we fucking bombed so bad.
And I remember afterwards drinking with this guy and,
uh,
we were both back at the hotel just laughing,
going,
I'm getting fired now.
I'm getting fired or whatever.
Nothing.
I don't know.
What stage was that?
Was that like the early run through of the show?
Was that the final no,
no,
this was,
uh,
we were getting ready to shoot the pilot.
Okay.
And we will,
we will coming up on it,
and I forget the name of the director,
but he was rehearsing the hell out of it.
So we will all,
like,
I remember the night when we shot it,
they toned everything down.
But like this guy of like rehearse is so much,
I was like,
this is like maniacal,
man.
This is crazy.
But I just remember the night when we finally went to shoot it,
there was only a couple of pickups,
so I totally understood the method,
method of his madness.
I just needed to do one episode with them.
Unfortunately,
it was the last one because he was a great director.
But,
um,
the,
uh,
at that point it was just the run through.
So we're already in there.
There's nobody in the bleachers.
There's no audiences,
no nothing.
Yeah.
And what,
what's funny is they did the first scene and usually the writers will sort of
laugh along and try to prime oh yeah.
The [inaudible] get here.
I mean,
some people who are writers,
uh,
who's,
who basically are only hired because they're good laughs.
Yeah.
Doing refers just to get people going.
But I think when they audibly gasped and it bombed,
and then we just,
the sound of shoes walking on the floor over to the fake living room to like to
the next thing.
I think everybody was like,
oh my God,
this,
you just felt it in the air.
And uh,
I think even the writers claimed they probably wanted to walk out.
It was a,
it's just the weirdest thing ever.
It was one of my favorite things I ever got to be in
that 22 minutes of just absolute utter so I can kind of bomb.
I can't even remember.
I can't even read the end.
If there was even any clapping.
I just remember this one actress face who was playing the mom.
She kind of like,
she did her line that bombed and then I did my line,
that bond who was classic like you know,
a [inaudible] movement of actors.
Yeah.
You say your thing and then you walk out this door is somebody else walks in,
you know,
just that sort of like a play.
And I just remember her walking just fucking look on her face.
Like she had just seen a ghost.
I don't know.
That's why I always like talking to you guys who came up through sketch because
I'm,
I've always been a huge,
huge fan and I just went the completely different,
uh,
the isolated way.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean at least the thing about sketch that's really nice and reassuring is
you're always out there with other people and you're also usually playing a
character.
So if you,
if you have a reaction that's just horrible,
you can blame it on the character.
You don't have to blame it on yourself,
which is the,
you know what's really tough about how you do it as like when you bomb,
it's,
you know,
Bill Burr is bombing.
They're not liking,
but the thing is as,
as it thing is,
you don't bump,
but as it hell yeah.
Oh yeah,
I do.
And I did for a long time.
As you bomb though,
you have the option to just pull the rip cord and go into something else.
Uh,
where you guys are just like,
it's like you're an a Bob sled and you just go down and you're picking up speed
going to this brick wall and there's no break and you just have to slam into the
thing.
But you just brought up like doing character.
So I wanted to,
uh,
cause we kind of,
I know you have this one was at wonder con.
You have to go to wondercon.
Um,
I want to do whenever I wanted to ask you like what is,
uh,
what are your favorite characters?
Um,
what do you do have a favorite character that you do?
Favorite gay characters that I,
that I do.
Yeah.
The most fun for you to do.
I love doing this character called Hamilton from SNL.
I didn't do it that many times,
but the funny thing is,
uh,
it's kind of this definitely a very odd,
insensitive,
uh,
racist,
just,
uh,
a Weirdo and,
and it's any,
he has this,
the police like this and he's just says crazy things too about society
and,
and it's so much fun to do this.
And,
and then,
uh,
Seth Meyers asked me to do the character,
at his,
uh,
his rehearsal dinner there.
He asked me to give a toast as this guy that was,
it's one of the most fun things I've ever done.
And then Andy Samberg's wedding was like two weeks later.
And so he,
he was at sets and he said,
oh,
we got to come do one of those for me.
So I've had so much fun.
How do you come up with doing that character?
And I don't have an outlet to do stuff like that that much anymore.
How do I grab it's late night.
Said,
SNL like your,
how do you just like don't think the little guy,
so this is a comic I'm so fascinated with with the sketch guys,
like how you do the thing.
Um,
uh,
I was watching when you doing the Tim Calhoon character,
oh,
Tim Calhoun.
And when you were like running for president,
I watched this clip this morning and you,
you were doing this thing with your fingers when you,
you do like,
like three with the left and then three with the right.
And you were just saying all this horribly like offensive stuff and you are you
speaking in like this whisper,
but like you,
you kind of captured like that,
uh,
like tell me runs for president.
If they're making it an annoying gesture.
Yeah.
Like they'll say,
oh,
don't do that.
That,
that seems rude.
And then you can just see them like,
so as they're trying to give this speech,
self conscious about what to do with their hands,
like you,
like we're picking up on that stuff.
And that's one of those things,
well,
I got to give the credit on that and like that,
that's something I used to do at the Groundlings.
And that's,
that's one of the things that I used as my audition piece.
Cause that was,
uh,
um,
but,
but I had written this thing and I was,
can you do a little bit of Tim Calhoun?
I don't want to put you on the spot.
I am Tim cow,
him
a United States senator.
Real prison.
Munis sits in America
since he read some of the things.
How do American needs another
big lake?
That's how I read it.
That's the worst rendition of that.
You were going to trade the,
the Grand Canyon for the Eiffel Tower.
And when they send us the Eiffel Tower,
we're not going to give them the Grand Canyon.
The
woman who was our director at the Groundlings,
she was the one who told me to do something with my hands and,
and even,
uh,
gave me these specific instructions.
So I had the,
the sheepish look in the,
the words I had.
I had written all that,
but,
but she gave me that,
which is such an important element of it.
So like,
that's,
you know,
that's one of the good things about sketch too is it's,
you've got this whole team of people around you who are,
who are helping to make everything better.
I don't,
I,
I think,
I think you'll one of the best,
Matt,
and I'm,
I'm so,
I'm so happy for you that you won't have those guys.
Like,
you know,
I didn't even bring up like Nebraska or all all this,
like that's a drama that will,
you know,
did,
uh,
somebody won an Oscar in that,
right?
Uh,
it was nominated and I have done any research in this and Emma,
we did.
Okay.
Right.
I think somebody wants something shiny.
No,
it was nominated for a bunch.
Uh,
Bruce dern was nominated.
Alexander Payne was nominated for directing it.
They was,
the film itself was nominated a June Squibb was nominated for,
uh,
for supporting actress.
It was,
uh,
it was,
I still can't believe I got to be a part of that.
Yeah.
Well,
I've been watching,
I've been,
obviously I was going to say I've been watching you.
That sounds creepy,
but I've been a fan of your career,
but I,
I you just seem like one of those guys where you,
uh,
you actually had the career that I love you.
You're like,
people know you but you're not like sucked into that,
uh,
you know,
entertainment tonight like to dye coming out of Starbucks,
sleep that will forte and some uggs,
like you weren't in that.
And I was just like watching,
like you said,
like this guy's making cool choices.
Everything that he makes is of quality,
whether you know,
and whenever you know,
you get a fucking movie,
you don't know what it's going to go up against,
whether it works or not,
but like you would just always like good in everything.
So when this thing came out,
um,
I was thinking like such an original idea,
oh my God,
will forte going to be it?
This is going to be,
you know,
exceeded expectations.
But I got to get Fox prompts because way back in the day they did a real,
um,
do you remember get a life with a Chris Elliot where yes,
he lived at home with his parents and he had a paper route and he was like in
his thirties.
That was just it.
He lived in the attic and it was just so fucking weird and like,
so like they do have a history of,
of uh,
oh my God doing stuff like that.
Many of those old like,
like I remember when Fox was,
was really young and,
and,
and yeah,
that show kid a life was so great that Garry Shandling show,
there's Shandling show.
Oh my God.
Mary was,
Sheldon was the one that blew up with children and Tracey Ullman show.
All those shows were the Simpsons and the Simpsons came out of that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
well dude,
you're,
they pass the baton to the right guy,
man.
I,
uh,
do you have anything that you want to promote before,
no rattle effortless hour here?
No,
I've,
I mean,
whatever.
I just want to say thank you to Fox and thank,
is there a night live two of the great experiences of my life.
All right.
And I just,
you know,
we talk about it and I go back and like I,
I go like God,
I hope,
you know,
I'll tell little stories about Saturday night live and I forget if I tell the
part,
which is like how appreciative I am to what an experience it was.
And like,
you know,
to Lauren,
none of this would be happening if it wasn't for him.
So,
you know,
what a great experience.
Well Dude,
you've been just little kiss ass.
That's the equivalent of me saying goodnight at the end of a party.
It's still in there.
Well listen man,
I am so psyched that you agreed to come on the podcast here.
Continued success.
I'm watching every episode.
Anybody listening,
if you haven't,
if you haven't been watching last man on earth,
uh,
definitely go out and try to get caught up when it,
because it's really one of the most original things that I've seen on TV in a
long time.
It's absolutely hilarious and crash.
Congratulations to all your cast members are Christian Shell,
January Jones,
Mel Rodriguez,
who's crushing it.
Um,
and that's it.
Enjoy your time down at wonder con,
whatever the hell that is.
And I have to run because he gets so tell healthcare I said hello.
I will.
All right,
that's it.
That's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Monday morning podcast on Friday.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Monday.